ginger is austin both second career
start
against miami and last start was august
18th that atlanta received the no
decision the nats eight to five win gave
up five runs on nine hits over five
struck out three walked three last time
out
86 pitches for austin 49 of those were
strikes
all right another day another baseball
game play ball
this one high in the air long run for
turner
and look where trey ends up almost out
into deep down the line left field
he just said where are you playing if
you read his lips
he was joking the other day that he's
playing two positions left field and
shortstop you see him take a peek at one
right there
the first baseman jesus aguilar stands
in
slang and a miss on a 94 heater
one of austin both best fastball so far
pablo lopez gets the ball as the marlins
try to take
three out of five from the washington
nationals again that 242 era
is ninth best in the national league
this guy has been fantastic
eaton the left-hand batter hitting 230
a home run six batted in now the pitch
of the way swinging a ground ball right
side
aguilar sprawls in the backhand to get
it from a knee he flips the lopez
covering and just in time to get eaten
on a really good play by the marlins
first baseman jesus aguilar
nationals have a base runner for the d.h
howie kendrick who's hitting 291. chop
to short miggy row goes this short way
pretty good first thanks to jesus
so birdie down at first after the first
walk and two on with this game scoreless
here in the third ing big batter here
for both
fights that one off and turner makes the
play
a high throw and it pulls thames off the
bag
so the inning will continue it's ruled a
single and the bases are loaded for
jesus aguilar
and a pitch that's in off the plate
aguilar
a good a b and that's going to score vr
and the marlins take a one-nothing lead
dickerson with a single in the second
inning
in the air for soto
a lot of hang time and that's it could
have been worse austin both
gets a huge out
ray alfaro at the plate and that gets
alfaro right in the
either in the back or the arm but he's
as tough as they come he'll jog down
first two on one out for jonathan vr
viara base it into left center field
that is going to bring home brian
anderson and jonathan vr with another
multi-hit effort and it's two-nothing
miami winning now it's up to matt joyce
marlon's looking to need a big two out
here from joyce or for the second inning
in a row it'll be a very unsatisfying
inning for miami don't want to sound
greedy but
all these base runners you got to cash
them in and that
is through a base hit for matt joyce
alfaro will score
and so will jonathan vr it goes through
the shift again the marlins have beaten
it a couple of times tonight they've got
a four nothing lead yeah you can beat
the shift when you've got plenty of exit
velocity
02 to aguilar and that's out to center
field roblaise is going back he turns
around he's gonna have to play it off
the wall
and he loses his footing joyce is coming
around he's going to score all the way
from first
aguilar into second two more runs home
six nothing marlins corey dickerson is
the ninth man to bat in this
inning and dickerson that's the base hit
aguilar is rounding third he will score
tack on another
the extra point puts the marlins up
seven to nothing
well the word that's starting to come to
mind is maybe payback for yesterday but
the offense is rolling tonight
here's eric thames who walked last time
[Applause]
short left center birdie and he lost it
in the twilight
over his head hustling his themes into
second
but what you're supposed to do is wave
your hands and throw an absolute fit
here but maybe he's trying to become he
did a little bit yeah
and then it came out and he knew he came
in too far that's victor robles
and row blaze jacks one to center birdie
back
he's got it two runners will move
forward and the nats are on the board
all right victor robles 11th rbi it's
7-1
and he will bat as adam eaton delivers
for adam the last two games three two
out rbis
it's a 7-2 game here's howie kendrick
who's grounded into a force play to the
shortstop
here come the nets eaton scores
soto the second and it's seven to three
three consecutive two out hits
throughout base runner has done a lot of
damage in this game with two out and
scored
six of their seven runs with two outs
john bertie
to the plate another row two coming from
bacchus and bertie sends one in the air
center field
turning around is roll blaze that's
gonna get out for a home run
a two-run shot for john bernie his first
of the year and the marlins get a couple
back
another big two out hit for the marlins
in this game
juan soto two for two career against
this lefty
where is this one going and how hard is
he going to hit it is the question
and he jacks one down into the right
field corner he's gonna hop into the
bullpen
and juan soto is four for four
his 17th rbi and now it's a nine to four
game
not a big spot for luis garcia white
delivers swinging a line drive base hit
right field
soto scores kendrick will stop as
sanchez gets to it quickly
it's now a 9-5 game sanchez down to
first base stickers in its second
and here's alfaro with one out
[Applause]
swinging 3-0 sends this one toward left
center field it will get down
and hop up bent over the wall he'll have
an rbi double as dickerson scores
and it's 10-5 marlins
up the middle throwing across his body
garcia that throw was off the mark
and rojas will reach sanchez scores it's
11-5
two walks in a row two on one out and
adam eaton will be the batter and adam
eaton
this one going deep to right see
you later his first homer since opening
night
and it's 11-8 and now
we dance and now we have a ball game
nats are down to their final out he's at
third with two out and eric thames the
batter
kitzler's 1-2 is a swing and a miss
it's a marlins win miami holds off
washington a wild one 11-8 the final
score